welcome back how is this the end of our  show already i'd love to use our last  few moments together to answer some of  your questions  first up social media questions were on  fire today done asking a tough one via  twitter waffles or pancakes neither  sausages hello virtual friends who has a  question christina  yes hi how are you good  i love you so much i love you too  christina do you have a question  i do i know that you you just seem so  fearless  and i just want to know what your  biggest fear is oh christina  my god that's a good question  i'm afraid of anything bad happening to  the people i love  that's probably a common fear you know  it's straight to the  protection the ones i love other than  that  i say in life you got to go for it and  be fearless  love the ones you love but go for it and  never forget to make the most of every  single day